إنه مشهد من الدمار التام هنا
في كل مكان تتجه إليه، إنه
مشاهد مروعة هنا يشبه منطقة حرب
تأثرت العديد من المدن عبر الساحل الليبي
بهذه العاصفة ولكن ما حدث
في الحمض النووي كان مختلفًا تمامًا، هذه الكارثة
كما يصفها الناس هنا كانت بالطبع
ناجمة عن  هذين السدين اللذين انفجرا
أطلقا العنان لكل المياه التي اجتاحت الفيضانات التي
اجتاحت هذه المدينة ودمرت
كل شيء تقريبًا في طريقها
وجرفت أحياء بأكملها
ومباني كاملة وبنية تحتية وعائلات
انتهى بها الأمر في البحر وأنت تتحدث إلى
الناس هنا الناجين الذين يصفون
ليلة من  الرعب الذي مروا به من
كل هذا الدمار، كل هذه الخسارة البشرية،
آلاف الأرواح التي فقدت،
أكثر من 10000 شخص في عداد
المفقودين الآن، يقولون إن
كل هذا حدث في غضون حوالي 90
دقيقة، تحدثنا إلى بعض الناجين
واصفين ذلك  كيف اضطروا أه يتسابقوا
لإنقاذ حياتهم أطفالهم يمسكون
بما يستطيعون أطفالهم ويركضون
ويحاولون الهروب من ارتفاع المياه
الذي استمر في الارتفاع بارتفاع ثلاثة طوابق
أه سمعنا أن الأمواج أه كانت
تصل إلى حوالي 22 قدمًا وتلك  الذين نجوا أصيبوا
بصدمة نفسية، تحدثت إلى
الناس الآن الذين بالكاد قادرين على
فهم ما حدث لهم، ما
حدث لمدينتهم، سكان مدينتهم في حالة
صدمة ويخبرك الليبيون أنهم
رأوا كل ما تعاملوا معه مع الحرب، لقد
رأوا الموت  لقد تعاملوا مع
الخسارة من قبل ولكن لا شيء أعدهم
لهذا، والآن مما
رأيناه ليس لديهم القدرات اللازمة
للتعامل مع كارثة بهذا الحجم،
هناك بعض فرق البحث والإنقاذ التي
جاءت من بلدان مختلفة
لكنها  أقول إن هذا ليس قريبًا بدرجة
كافية، فهم بحاجة إلى المزيد، لقد رأينا
الكثير من المتطوعين هنا في هذا
البلد المقسم بشدة، البلد الذي
تقاتلت فيه المدينة، المدينة الشرقية تقاتل الغرب
منذ أكثر من عقد من الزمان، وقد رأينا
أشخاصًا من جميع أنحاء البلاد الذين
سكب في الحمض النووي الذين تدفقوا
إلى الشرق لمحاولة دعم
الناس لمساعدة المتطوعين في البحث والإنقاذ
أه يحاولون أه المساعدة في انتشال
الجثة على حد تعبير امرأة
تحدثنا إليها سابقًا قائلة إن هذه الكارثة
وحدت شعب ليبيا و
يبدو أن لديها على الأقل في
الوقت الراهن